[Musique]
c'est peut-être parce qu'on était au
sommet de la première vague de kobe 19
qu'on en a moins parlé la pire tuerie de
masse dans l'histoire récente du canada
le drame de portes à pic à ce moment là
je croyais que c'était un événement
isolé comme un drame familial et que ce
gars là n'étaient pas à la recherche
d'innocents pour les tuer
dans la nuit du 18 avril gabriel buono
fait un carnage dans cette petite
communauté de la nouvelle écosse 22
victimes innocentes des mères des pères
de famille
une nuit d'horreur qui a duré treize
longues heures avant que le tueur ne
soit finalement battu
pendant des heures et des heures alors
que des gens mouraient brûlée vive
jusqu'ici toutes ces heures pour réagir
on n'a pas posé cette semaine on vous
présente l'anc est bouleversante de nos
collègues du festin qui sont retournés
voir les familles des victimes parce
qu'il vient de nombreuses questions
auxquelles la grc refusent toujours de
répondre
c'est incroyable qu'ils aient cru à sa
mort il est vu leurs erreurs que quand
les meurtres repos c'est marie maude
denis
bienvenue à enquête
m
portas pic est une communauté tranquille
niché sur la côte de la baie de fundy
c'est la région des chalets de la
nouvelle écosse mais la nuit du 18 avril
plusieurs incendies sont allumés dans la
région d'abord il y a eu des coups de
feu puis des récits se sont répandus sur
facebook j'ai des amis dans la région de
pôle québec
il disait qu'il y avait des flammes plus
haute que la cime des arbres et qu'il y
aurait eu des coups de feu
je n'y ai pas accorder d'importance
jusqu'à ce que j'apprenne que ça se
passait sur le chemin de portes au
public
porte à pic sur le chemin beach road
c'est tout près de la maison du père de
tiger blur de sa femme jamie et de leurs
deux jeunes garçons
leurs voisins s'appelle gabriel borkman
walkman est un denturologiste mais dans
voisinage il ne passe pas inaperçu avec
ses nombreuses armes à feu et son
mauvais caractère et cette nuit là il va
se déchaîner
je pense que mon père était devant la
maison au moment où gabriel est arrivé
des voisins ont entendu mon père crier
qu'est ce que tu fais avec un fusil
c'est là qu'il l'a abattu j'ai mis un
couru jusqu'à la porte elle a fait
entrer les enfants dans la maison et a
couru avec eux s'enfermer dans leur
chambre
mes deux petits frères se sont cachés
derrière le lit jamie ces plaques et le
dos contre la porte mais il a tiré à
travers la porte les policiers lui
apprendront plus tard que ses parents
furent les premières victimes de walkman
sa belle mère était en ligne avec le 9 à
1 quand elle a été tué gémit je sais
comme une merde
depuis presque 20 ans c'est une des plus
belles personnes qui soient
après avoir vu leurs parents mourir
les deux garçons de 10 et 12 ans se
cache dans le garde-robe mai et
comprennent que le tireur a commencé à
mettre le feu à leur maison ils ont
senti la fumée mais c'était la fumée des
coups de feu mon petit frère est sorti
de la maison et avec le tireur avait
retiré des bus du peu et il est
répandait partout sur le plancher puis
il a ouvert le poil au propane
il réalise alors qu'il faut s'enfuir
il s'enfonce dans la forêt jusqu'à la
maison la plus proche celle de l'esam
école
ses deux enfants le lait ça est
enseignante
[Musique]
bâle
issa était tellement dynamique
c'était l'expression même de la vie
[Musique]
son humour sa musique sa façon de mordre
dans chaque moment de la vie
elle n'avait peur de rien elle était une
vraie maman ours prêt à protéger et à
aider tout le monde
c'est pour ça qu'elle était sortie quand
elle a vu les flammes qui dépassaient la
cime des arbres
elle a vu un agent de la grc et lui a
probablement demander s'il fallait
évacuer ce qui s'était passé et elle a
été tuée
nous savons maintenant que les 18 et 19
avril le tireur portaient des pièces
d'un uniforme authentique de la grc dont
une chemise et un pantalon avec une
ligne jaune
les jours suivants les événements la grc
reste aussi stupéfaite que les citoyens
ordinaires les premiers agents sur les
lieux parle d'une scène de chaos
le nez sur la gueule
ils partent tout de suite à la recherche
du tireur
selon les politiques de la grc mais il
ne trouve que des corps libère lice à
mes cordes et dix autres victimes
s'ajouteront à la liste
cory hersen genzyme est heureuse bateau
me donne et fringues guan xin zhao et
pilote émérite à issy parents et rémi
jouines la région
à 23h30 de samedi la grc lance son
premier avertissement public un tweet
qui ne parlent ni d' incendies ni de
gens abattus
juste une plainte pour arme à feu et
l'avertissement aux gens de portes à pic
de ne pas sortir de chez eux
à près de 50 km de portes à pic au nord
de la ville de trop
nick bilton et sa femme christine
suivent ou si les événements sur
facebook on a parlé de ce qui circulait
avant de se coucher puis ça finit par se
calmer
comme travailleuse en santé
communautaire christine se rendait
souvent dans des régions comme porte un
pic mis cette nuit là nul danger
imminent me semblait à crête
j'étais inquiet pour les gens de ce coin
là pas pour nous ça ne se passait pas
dans la même région du tout il ya
beaucoup d'autres villages entre le
nôtre et porte à pic
cependant la famille d'une autre
infirmière une collègue de christine
s'inquiétait de son côté éleveurs brian
connaissait bien les blair de porter
pique sa fille de16 fut la première à
prendre l'horrible nouvelle base il
était 5h30 quand mon mari m'a réveillé
après être sorti de la maison le matin
du 19
on ne savait pas trop encore ce qui
s'était passé j'ai appelé ma mère pour
lui dire que jamie et collègues étaient
morts et que je ne savais pas ce qui
leur était arrivé
déjà durant la nuit la grc soupçonnait
al interne que workman était impossible
suspect mais les policiers disent que ce
n'est qu'à l'aube qu'un témoin est venue
confirmer leurs soupçons
quelqu'un a frappé à ma porte
c'était la conjointe de m j'ai ouvert je
les fais entrer en vitesse puis j'ai
claqué la porte en navire orient elle
lui a dit s'être caché toute la nuit
dans la forêt dans sa déposition elle a
ajouté que works ne l'avait pas dessus
est attachée elle était entrée elle
n'arrivait plus à tenir en place et la
digue et bryant est devenu fou j'ai dit
oui il vient de brûler sa maison et la
panique et je les mises dans la salle de
bain et j'ai fait la fin
nos agents se sont présentés sur place
et c'est à ce moment là que grâce à un
témoin important
nous avons appris plus de détails au
sujet de gabriel borkman dont le fait
qu'il possédait une réplique de
véhicules de police à l'éffigie de la
grc ayant tout l'équipement nécessaire
et porte un uniforme de police mais où
se trouvait le véhicule est ou était
world men
[Musique]
plus de douze heures après notre arrivée
à porte à pic
le service 9-1-1 a commencé à recevoir
une deuxième série d'appels venant d'un
secteur situé à plus de 60km de portes à
pic
ce secteur et la vallée de wentworth à
45 minutes de là en voiture les appels
provenaient d'un autre groupe de chaleil
de maisons campagne situé sur le chemin
entre les voisins m'ont textile pour
savoir si on avait entendu des coups de
feu tôt en matinée
j'ai dit non mais là j'entends quelque
chose et à ce moment il y a eu une
énorme explosion
je leur ai dit mon dieu avez vous
entendu ça qu'est ce qui se passe et ils
ont répondu ne vosges pas de chez toi
il y un fou dangereux sur la route des
caméras de surveillance sur le chemin
routeur haut capter des images
ressemblant à une voiture de la grc à
6h30 du matin près de la maison diana
jenkins et shine et cloud
trois heures plus tard lorsque la
voiture repart il était mort as tu une
idée de la raison pour laquelle il s'en
est pris à m
[Musique]
peut-être parce qu'ils étaient heureux
car elle rendait jaloux il enviait
peut-être leur vie je n'en ai aucune
idée
c'est la seule explication qu'il
connaissait jenkins et deux agents
correctionnels il élevait deux filles
dont amiria 18 ans il était vraiment
attentionné généreux plein d'amour drôle
leur maison était toujours ouverte
leur maison fut aussi incendié
leurs voisins tamba galeries venues voir
ce qui se passait fut aussi tué tout
comme les lianes hislop qui passait tout
près lors de sa promenade du matin
wentworth le chemin en tulle ceux ci
dessus à environ 40 km du village de
deih woerth et dimanche matin christine
biten se préparait à se rendre
travailler dans la région
elle partait pour aller travailler il
était très tôt 6 ou 7 heures je ne sais
plus trop et les revenus elle m'a donné
un gros baiser est un gros câlin me
disant bébé était le meilleur et j'étais
loin c'était loin de me douter que ce
serait son dernier baiser si tout
dernier
[Musique]
durant son trajet christine garder un
oeil sur les nouvelles via facebook
peu avant 10 heures elle a appelé nick
pour lui dire que quelqu'un venait de
lui partagé un nouveau tweet de la grc
nommant gabriel borkman comme le suspect
de portes à pic
je me rappelle que j'ai écrit son nom
sur un bout de papier et que j'ai dit à
kristen que j'allais trouver la page
facebook du huga je pourrais lui envoyer
une photo pour qu'elle reconnaisse comme
ça elle pourrait l'éviter
à ce moment là je croyais que c'était un
événement isolé comme un drame familial
et que ce gars là n'étaient pas à la
recherche d'innocents pour les tuer
donc je lui ai envoyé la photo la photo
de ce type et c'est la dernière chose
qu'elle a lus
cadeau au braille n était-elle aussi sur
la route elle venait voir ses enfants
qu'elle savait bouleversé par le sort
que venait de subir la famille blair on
a un forum familiale sur le web
ma mère a écrit pour savoir ce qu'on
voulait comme café car elle venait nous
voir ils se doutaient bien que les
nouvelles de portes à pic nous rendaient
tous assez nerveux je pense qu'elle
voulait s'assurer qu'on allait bien
brian et christine boutin elle est toute
de mourir à trois cents mètres l'une de
l'autre sur la même route rurale à 9h59
elle nous a écrit un texto qui
mentionnait deux choses d'abord gr 6
puis coups de feu à des bottes avec fait
je crois qu'elle s'est retrouvé
exactement sur les lieux du meurtre de
huit ans d'études
quand il s'est produit bas le meurtrier
s'est dit qu'elle avait peut-être été
témoins qu'elle en avait trop vu ou
entendu comme tout match à elle s'est
trouvée au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
douze heures après le premier meurtre
le bilan des morts s'élève déjà à 10 9
et le tireur déguisé en policier
poursuit son oeuvre
il y à 50 km entre déborde et le secteur
de shubenacadie est à nouveau les
caméras de surveillance capte le trajet
de word semaine lors d'un arrêt il
retire tranquillement sa veste avant de
continuer dt mois commence a signalé
avoir vu le suspect comme la grc n'avait
pas bloqué les routes durant la nuit
elle décide d'envoyer des agents placé
des barrages routiers les agents tchad
morrison et ray stevenson doivent se
rencontrer pour aller en italien
les agents se parlait sur les ondes de
leur voiture un véhicule ayant toutes
les apparences d'une voiture de la grc
s'est approché de celui de l'agent
morrison qui a cru qu'il s'agissait de
lagence t25 c'est plutôt le tireur qui
était au volant de cette voiture il
s'est immobilisé à côté du véhicule de
l'agent molson et a immédiatement fait
feu
morrison survie à l'attack ce n'est pas
le cas pour stevenson
quelques minutes plus tard workman
embouti sa voiture puis lui prend son
arme de service
et là dessus il dit aussi joe webb qui
croyait se courir des accidentés
puis ils incendient toutes les voitures
[Musique]
la dernière victime du tueur
fuji naboulet une collègue
denturologiste qui habitait dans le
secteur après l'avoir assassiné workman
a volé sa voiture et a roulé 21 km avant
de manquer d'essence
ce fut uniquement à ce moment et
seulement parce que l'escouade tactique
de la grc avait aussi décidé d'arrêter à
cette station service pour faire le
plein que la folie meurtrière a
finalement cessé
et médiatique
lorsque l'agent est sorti de son
véhicule il y a eu une altercation entre
lui le tireur et celui ci a été abattu à
plus haut et fort
[Musique]
un massacre qui dure 13 heures et qui
fait 22 morts après la pause on va
revenir en détail sur le trajet de
gabriel workman et se demandait comment
se fait-il qu'il a réussi à parcourir
plus de 200 km sans être arrêté vous
pensez qu'il est passé par là c'est sûr
qu'il est passé par ici
[Musique]
on
sept mois après les meurtres de 22
néo-écossais le deuil se poursuit des
questions alourdissent la douleur du
deuil que savait la grc
quand elle fait pour tenter d'arrêter le
meurtrier des vies aurait-elle pu être
épargnées
tout s'est passé tellement vite je crois
que personne n'aurait pu aider lit ça à
mon avis pour la sauver il aurait fallu
remonter dix ans auparavant en 2002
gabriel borkman avait été condamné pour
voies de fait en 2010 la police l'avait
soupçonné d'avoir menacé ses parents son
père se rappelle avoir dit à la police
que workman possédait des armes à feu en
une autre information est transmise aux
autorités la police municipale de
taureaux apprend que whitman conserve la
plupart de ces armes dans son chalet de
portes à pic
la source révèle même aux policiers que
walkman est atteint de troubles mentaux
il raconte qu'il veut tuer un policier
il fallait protéger la population mais
aussi les agents sur le terrain vu le
sérieux des menaces notre policière et
publié ces informations pour que tous
les corps policiers de la province y
aient accès mais ce n'est pas la police
de taureaux qui a juridiction apporte à
pic
c'est la grc un agent de la grc a bien
rendu visite à watchmen mais sans aucune
suite
deux ans plus tard une autre plainte a
été déposée à la grc au sujet des armes
à feu des gabriel borkman quand on a
connu on la trouvait plutôt logique
il avait appris que moi et ne marie
étions dans les forces armées et nous a
montré toutes ses armes des armes
illégales et en plus l'afrique et nous a
demandé si on pouvait lui procurer des
armes et des munitions militaires
nous lui avons dit non vous n'avez pas
droit
c'est illégal
madame forbes a informé la grc au sujet
des armes et a aussi déclaré que workman
battait sa conjointe de détails vous
ont-ils dit qu'il enquêterait ils n'ont
pas dit qu'ils ouvriraient une enquête
mais qu'ils allaient suivre le dossier
et ils ont ajouté qu'ils ne pourraient
sans doute rien faire parce que je ne
leur avait pas fourni de preuve qu'ils
possédaient bel et bien ses armes comme
des photos les néo écossais ont de
nombreuses questions sur les événements
et pourquoi ils ont eu lieu sur les
gestes posés et sur ceux qui ne l'ont
pas été soyez certains que nous
partageons ces questions cette enquête
entend bien y répond partage depuis le
drame peu de réponses sont venues de la
grc
la plupart des informations ont été
soutirés à la grc en cours par les
médias mais elles ont aussi été obtenus
par les familles des victimes qui ont
mené leur propre enquête
[Musique]
j'ai bien l'impression que la grc ne
souhaite pas que l'on fasse toute la
lumière sur ce qu'elle a fait et sur sa
réaction au moment de la tragédie
pourquoi ne pas faire toute la lumière
je pense que ça la mettrait en oeuvre
par exemple la grc refusent toujours de
donner le nombre exact d'agents envoyés
sur le terrain apporte à pic
au tout début du déploiement policier
ainsi que l'heure d'arrivée des renforts
mais elle maintient que les premiers
répondants étaient des héros qui ont
immédiatement confronté la menace se
décline comme ils l'ont appris pendant
leur formation ils avaient pour objectif
de trouver et d'arrêter la menace c'est
ce que les premiers intervenants de la
grc ont tenté de faire mais un témoin
révèle n'avoir aucune preuve d'une telle
intervention
sauf à l'arrivée de l'équipe d'urgence
venu d'halifax
deux heures après le début du drame
selon les témoins la première
intervention de la grc n'impliquaient
que trois voitures de police toutes
stationnés au bout de la route
à mon avis à ce moment là les agents
tentaient de sécuriser la scène du crime
il ne cherchait pas à neutraliser le
tireur
et ça aurait pu sauver des vies d'autres
citoyens ont aussi eu la même impression
tu es resté caché dans la forêt quatre
heures a gelé les yeux aussi un
cherchant des joueurs de gyrophare qui
ne sont jamais venus jamais pendant des
heures des heures alors que des gens
mouraient brûlée vive jusqu'ici toutes
ces heures pour réagir
[Musique]
souvenez-vous ses deux enfants qui ont
vu leurs parents se faire abattre devant
eux
ils ont gardé leur calme et sont restés
à l'abri
ils ont comprendre la fuite à travers la
forêt jusqu'à la maison voisine
ils sont entrés s'y cacher avec les deux
jeunes enfants de l'isam écuries ils se
sont cachés au sous sol et ont appelé le
9 à 1
ils ont parlé avec les enfants les ont
aidés à garder leur calme et leur ont
donné un mot de passe ils leur ont dit
de sortir de la maison juste si
quelqu'un leur dise est ce mot de passe
mais pour eux aussi le temps c'est
affreusement allongée de plus de deux
heures devrait pas laisser quatre jeunes
enfants tout seul pendant deux heures
quand un fou dangereux se promène tout
près de là avec un fusil savez vous
pourquoi ils ont fait ça
des membres de la famille mais qu ils
disent que la grc leur a assuré qu'au
moins six agents étaient postés autour
de la maison pour protéger des enfants
mais ce n'est pas ce que la grc a dit à
tyler et il n'en croit rien ok mais
pourquoi ne pas avoir aussi envoyé un
agent les sortir de là d'après ce que
vous savez de la situation est-ce que
des policiers protégé la maison ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup
non non non pourquoi parce que la grc a
déjà menti tellement de fois j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté à croire la
moindre de leurs explications
peu importe ce qui se passait vraiment
sur le terrain
la grc a passé la nuit à chercher des
véhicules relié à gabriel borkman y
compris trois ancien véhicule de police
à l'aube
les trois véhicules étaient retrouvés et
la grc a fait une grave erreur
deportivo ils ont conclu que walkman
était mort qu'il s'était suicidé et que
son corps se trouvaient dans un de ses
bâtiments
une source à la grc a confirmé
l'information
on a même été jusqu'à renvoyer certains
agents chez eux
ce n'est qu'après que la grc a appris
l'existence d'une quatrième voiture elle
ignorait autre chose d'essentiel porter
pic avait une sortie secret un chemin de
terre longeant un champ de bleuets
vous pensez qu'il est passé par là c'est
sûr qu'il est passé par ici
la grc à présumer qu'il s'était suicidé
si ça leur faisait plaisir le croire
mais sinon c'est route était sa seule
façon de s'en fuir et tout le monde ici
connaît cette route
mais la grc ne s'est pas renseigné cette
nuit là selon lui quand il vous dit aux
agents qu'il était sorti par ici c'est
incroyable qu'ils aient cru à s'amariner
vu leurs erreurs que quand les meurtres
repris ils auraient pu s'enfuir quitter
le pays et profiter de la situation mais
il s'est plutôt déplacer à sa guise
durant treize heures passant même la
nuit dans un parc industriel au nez et à
la barbe des policiers avant de
reprendre la route
j'ai grandi ici je sais qu'il ya très
peu de points d'entrée ou de sortie
il aurait pu bloquer les routes ils
n'ont rien fait aucun barrage ça aussi
je n'y comprends rien un seul barrage et
glenn room leur ait empêché de se rendre
à oneworld
ils auraient pu l'arrêter avant qu'ils
ne commettent ces meurtres
les 19 des voitures de police aurait dû
couvrir toute la région
il fallait prévenir les corps de police
locaux mais comme rien n'a été fait il
n'a pas été arrêté mais le chef de
police de taureau n'a rien su jusqu'à la
semaine suivante
ça ne s'est pas passé sur notre
territoire mais juste à côté
évidemment la sécurité de la population
et notre priorité ainsi que celle de nos
agents donc toute information qu'on
aurait pu nous transmettre aurait été
précieux
dimanche matin la police de tours au
rappel des policiers supplémentaires
pour aider la grc
celle ci refuse l'offre de taureaux tout
comme celle de la municipalité voisine
la grc choisi de faire appel à des
renforts alain terne venue des postes
d'halifax et de moncton situé à 1h30 de
route
un tel nombre de policiers convergent de
l'extérieur vers porte à pic rend la
communication très complexes jusqu'à
presque devenir fatal dans le canton
voisin dans ce lot voyant que watchmen a
fui porte à pic
la grc transmet à tous les services de
police un avis de recherche concernant
une fausse auto patrouille alors qu'un
policier monte la garde devant la
caserne des pompiers d'oslo une autre
voiture de la grc approche après
quelques minutes c'est la fusillade
quand j'ai entendu les coups de feu
j'étais juste ici en avant quelqu'un est
entré en criant cachez-vous tout le
monde à terre il ya des coups de feu les
deux policiers sont sortis de la voiture
en courant y en a un qui s'est caché
dans le fossé et l'autre derrière les
poubelles de l'autre côté de la rue
chine mclaren est horrifié de voir les
agents du nouveau véhicule se mettre à
tirer se sont mis à tirer
j'ai commencé à paniquer parce que je
croyais que le tireur était la ferme
mais il n'y avait pas de meurtriers je
ne comprenais plus rien le policier dans
son auto a levé les mains on voyait
qu'il voulait dire ne tirez pas je suis
un policier j'ignore le type d'armes
qu'ils avaient mais ils ont fait plus de
trente deux trous dans la caserne
c'était le chaos le chaos total
vous venez de voir qu'il ya eu des
problèmes de communication entre les
policiers sur le terrain cette nuit là
après la pause
vous allez voir comment la grc ont
négligé de donner des informations
cruciales à la population des
informations qui auraient pu sauver des
vies si la chaire si nous avait dit ce
qu'elles savaient dès 11h samedi soir je
n'aurais jamais pris la route
il serait resté à la maison
[Musique]
en situation d'urgence
l'information sauvent des vies lors de
cette terrible fin de semaine d'avril ou
22 néo-écossais allait perdre la vie la
grc n'a pas émis d'alerté de sécurité
provinciale
elle a plutôt choisi les médias sociaux
pour parler au public
on voyait toute l'information sur
twitter
et ça ça me met hors de moi et pas juste
moi tous les gens à qui j'en ai parlé
la grc a tweeté 10 fois en 13 heures
elle l'a fait en s'attendant à ce que
les médias locaux diffuse ses messages
de cette manière le public sort est que
ces messages contenaient les
informations les plus complètes est
récente mais on sait maintenant que
c'était une erreur
rappelons nous de ce qu'est la grc a dit
des détails cruciaux qu'elle obtenait
sur le tireur c'est à ce moment là que
témoin important nous a pris plus de
détails dans le fait qu'il possédait une
réplique de véhicules de police à
l'éffigie de la grc ayant tout
l'équipement nécessaire et il porte un
uniforme de police la grc dit que cette
information lui venu de la conjointe de
walkman après qu'elle soit sorti de sa
cachette dimanche matin avant ces
renseignements nous était inconnu
nous avons obtenu l'essentiel des
informations sur le suspect à ce moment
là
mais nous avons appris que la grc avait
les mêmes détails
au moins huit heures avant dé diffuser
dès la rencontre du premier témoin
apporte à pic
cet homme n'a jamais été identifié
publiquement
il conduisait sa voiture lorsque workman
l'a tiré et blessé il n'a pas voulu
accorder d'entrevue
mais il a fait une déclaration policiers
à 22h30 le soir du drame
sur cet enregistrement obtenu par le
fifth estate
il explique à un détective privé ce
qu'il a dit aux policiers
le lettrage rendait la voiture identique
à une auto patrouille
il semble que ce témoin était crédible
pour la grc
parce qu'un rapport de police interne à
une heure du matin
identifie world mine comme le suspect et
le lie à une vieille voiture de police
blanches sept heures plus tard une mise
à jour la décrit comme une voiture de
police complètement laiteries et donne
son numéro mais ce qui est aussi
important c'est qu'il est précisé que
workman pourrait se trouver n'importe où
dans la province environ à la même heure
que ce rapport interne la grc envoie un
nouveau tweet un tireur actif est à
l'oeuvre
mais le danger est circonscrit à porter
pic 50 minutes plus tard un autre tweet
identifie whitman sans mentionner où il
se trouverait la grc ne partage aucune
des autres informations reçues durant la
nuit
j'ai lu et relu tous que la grc a publié
elle n'a jamais dit qu'il portait un
uniforme ou qui conduisait une voiture
de police
si la grc nous avait dit ce qu'elles
savaient dès 11h samedi soir je n'aurais
jamais pris la route
elle serait restée à la maison pour ré
de o'brian cette information est venue
trop tard et après la mort de maman qui
l'ont publié l'information qu'il était
dans la région de bienne drôme
c'est après sa mort qui l'ont dit qu'il
conduisait une voiture de la grc
c'est après tout ça après j'avais déjà
tout ça c'est depuis des heures la
veille
o'brian ebit n'ont été assassiné peu
après 10 heures dimanche matin à 10h17
la grc a finalement fait part des
informations essentielles qui selon les
familles auraient pu sauver les deux
femmes ainsi que d'autres victimes
c'est la première fois qu'on fournisse
et ses détails à la population en
matinée à 10h17
oui ça aurait pu changer quelque chose
sans aucun doute c'est votre mère avait
eu ces détails oui ça aurait tout changé
pour ma mère et aussi pour les liens
hislop et christine boutin
et pour giuly wever jean a coulé
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont omis
d'informer la population pour qu'elle
puisse se protéger ils n'ont rien fait
heather bright y avait huit enfants et
douze petits enfants
[Musique]
ma mère c'était la beauté c'est le mot
qu'il a décrit le mieux
elle était prête à tout faire pour les
gens et leur ai donné sa chemise à ben
c'est comme si
si elle avait su qu'elle devait
concentrer toute une vie d'amour en
trois ans notre vie était parfaite
tout était si parfait elle venait
d'apprendre qu'elle était enceinte
on souhaitait en avoir un deuxième
et ça a marché il était tellement
heureux tout semblait nous sourire on
vivait au jour le jour mais ça ne nous
dérangeait pas
on était là l'un pour l'autre avec un
garçon en bonne santé un autre qui s'en
venait
dans un instant on va vous révéler
d'autres détails touchant au sujet des
victimes
vous allez comprendre pourquoi leurs
familles sont décidés à obtenir toutes
les réponses
mon père a retrouvé des douilles dans
l'habitacle ils n'ont jamais nettoyé la
voiture il restait encore des lambeaux
d'elle dans la voiture quand ils nous
l'ont rendu aux médailles
[Musique]
après la tragédie
la nouvelle écosse toute entière a
manifesté son soutien aux familles des
22 victimes
mais quand ces familles se sont mises à
poser des questions au gouvernement et à
la police ce fut le silence radio
oh
la grc ne m'a absolument rien appris je
ne sais rien de plus qu'en avril ou en
mai dernier
vous en pensez quoi je ne sais pas quoi
penser
je crois que c'est une ligne on ne
devrait pas avoir à se battre pour des
réponses ou a supplié c'est comme ça que
je le vois
mais il devait se battre il parce qu'ils
ont fait il y aura une enquête publique
les conclusions ne sont pas attendues
avant moins deux ans chaque famille vit
encore avec des questions qui font mal
et si la grc n'avait pas présumer que
watchmen était mort je leur ai posé la
question et n'ont pas pu me répondre
ils ont dit qu'il ferait des recherches
et me reviendrait toujours rien et ça
fait des mois
la grc soutient que le fait que watson
s'est fait passer pour un agent de la
grc n'a joué aucun rôle dans la mort de
qui que ce soit
le tireur n'a pas utilisé sa réplique de
voitures de la grc pour intercepter les
victimes dans leur véhicule
nous savons qu'au moins trois victimes
se sont arrêtés en voyant une voiture de
la grc
parce que salir assurée ou qu'elle
voulait faire leur devoir de citoyen
vous que les agents leur semblait en
difficulté
dire qu'un véhicule ou un uniforme de
police n'ont pas influencé les victimes
est une affirmation mensongère
la famille o'brian soutient qu'on lui a
menti
on leur a expliqué que heather bright
and avait été atteinte par le tireur qui
se trouvait de l'autre côté du chemin à
une certaine distance
oui non nous savons qu'il était en fait
que sa main et son arme était à
l'intérieur de la voiture
comment le savez-vous parce que mon père
a retrouvé des douilles dans l'habitacle
ils n'ont jamais nettoyé la voiture
quand ils nous l'ont remise
on a retrouvé beaucoup d'éléments de
preuve
quels éléments
tu as où il restait encore des lambeaux
d'elle dans la voiture quand ils nous
l'ont rendue au mégarama les familles
poursuivre maintenant la grc et la
province de la nouvelle écosse pour
négligence tout ce qu'on veut c'est des
réponses la vérité et de la transparence
on peut la grc admettre qu'elle a échoué
qu'elle a fait des erreurs et qu'elle va
tirer des leçons pour ne plus que ça se
reproduise
elle devrait déjà être en train de faire
cette analyse ils font quoi
la grc refusent de répondre à cette
question ou à toute autre question
puisque l' enquête n'est pas complété
en juin à millas mekouar a gradué de
l'école secondaire mais sans son père
c'était une dure journée très émotif
avais tu changes et a scoré été cette
journée si ton père avait encore été en
vie ça aurait été bien plus joyeux il
aurait été la civière
ils auraient été tous les deux
[Musique]
modérez votre mère devant une telle
situation comme je le dis souvent si la
même chose s'était passé pour moi une
demi soeur mon frère mon père elle en
aurait fait autant sinon plus elle ne se
serait pas contenté de demi mesure et
l'aurait exigé la vérité et leur était
bien pire que moi
les gens trouvent que j'en fais trop que
je prend de la place mais les agents de
la grc aurait été terrorisés de la voir
débarquer il n'aurait jamais accepté de
se faire dire non
[Musique]
vous dirigez l'entreprise familiale
maintenant oui c'était prévu que je
prenne la relève mais pas si vite ni de
cette façon et maintenant vous prenez
soin de vos frères quel âge avez-vous 27
ans tout ce poids sur vos épaules à 27
ans ouais je fais ce que j'ai à faire ce
que mon père voudrait que je fasse je
pourrais pleurer il ne rien faire mais
ce n'est pas ce que kristen voudrais
vous a pu me battre je ne vais pas
m'arrêter
j'ai vu
j'ai tenté de faire une pause pour
guérir pour encaisser tout ça mais ce
n'est pas moi je veux des réponses
j'ai dit assez c'est assez je suis prêt
à me battre
[Musique]
en décembre il ya eu des développements
dans cette triste histoire
la conjointe de fait de gabriel world
mine ainsi que deux autres personnes ont
été accusés de lui avoir procuré des
munitions illégalement il est encore tôt
pour tirer des conclusions d'ailleurs la
grc dit que ces trois personnes qui sont
accusés n'avaient pas conscience de ce
que gabriel borkman allait faire de ces
munitions entre temps les familles des
victimes fonde beaucoup d'espoir sur l'
enquête publique qui a été déclenchée
sur le drame de portes à pic
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez été touché par le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
revenez nous la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]